[Musique]
on
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous recevons renaud charles
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes le
cofondateur et rédacteur en chef deng
largeur pervis vous le présenter comme
un média local consacré à la culture et
aux initiatives positives dans le grand
paris il a été lancé en 2013
d'abord pourquoi avoir relancé ce média
parce qu'il manquait cruellement
tout simplement on était journaliste
mais on était aussi tous les fondateurs
de ce média des habitants de banlieue et
puis on ne trouvait pas justement quel
quel média pour sortir autour de chez
nous sans forcément aller à paris et on
s'est dit que si on trouvait pas
d'information c'est sans doute qu'ils
aient par le média pour nous raconter
pour une partager cette information
et comme on avait sept cette compétence
deux journalistes on s'est dit que
puisque ce média cement puisque ce média
manquer on allait le crest et depuis se
met bien a trouvé son audience son
public puisque on est parti on était
quelques centaines à enfin l'élection
n'était quelque 100 que quelques
centaines à lire les nageurs parisse
aujourd'hui ils sont près de 200 milles
par mois à ce s'informer sur une largeur
paris en ligne il ya quand même des
livres et des guides qui sont sortis on
en parlera après mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut trouver sur ce site ya plusieurs
catégories c'est ça oui alors au départ
en fait quand on a voulu créer un à jour
parisse on a voulu d'un média culturel
parce que comme je vous le disais en
tant que habitants de banlieue ont
recherché des informations pour savoir
quoi faire le week-end on se met enfin
une information plutôt orienté culture
et loisirs et on a on a très vite
ressenti le besoin de partager d'autres
informations parce que parler de la vie
culturelle c'est important mais il faut
pour pouvoir se projeter dans ces
territoires savoir ce qui s'y passe
savoir quelles sont les initiatives
chi chi chi j comme on vit et donc on a
on a commencé à parler beaucoup
d'économie sociale et solidaire on a
commencé à parler de l'agriculture den
de nature de sujets de société ont fait
son stage et puis on a élargi à des
choses aussi un peu plus un peu plus
légères comme les restaurants alors on
va pouvoir à nouveau retrouvé un peu
maintenant à nouveau fréquentés et donc
ça nous fait un média qui est un média
généraliste qui traite de l'actualité en
fin de l'actualité pas de l'actualité à
proprement parler de l'île de france en
tout cas d'une dune informations
pratiques et sociétal
donc voilà le but c'était de montrer
aussi que paris s'est extrêmement bien
mais à proximité de la capitale
il ya aussi énormément de choses qui
foisonnent c'est ça le butin en fait on
aime
j'aime beaucoup les chiffres et il ya un
chiffre qui me paraît important en fête
à partager avec vous c'est que l'île de
france c'est tout le monde attend 10
millions d'habitants pour se figurer un
petit peu ce que ça représente
c'est plus que la grèce et c'est plus
que le portugal et le problème de ceux
de cette région c'est qu' il n'existe
pas véritablement de média régional
c'est à dire qu'en dehors de france 3
paris région il n'existe pas de médias
de presse écrite vraiment d'essences
régionales le parisien est un média
avant tout qui traite de l'information
en département mais qui n'a pas ne
partent pas ce regard régionales comme
peuvent le faire les journaux comme
ouest france d'autres grands titres de
la presse quotidienne régionale et c'est
essentiel dans une région comme
l'ile-de-france que l'informant que
l'information puisse circuler entre les
départements on n'imagine pas dans un
pays comme le portugal que les listes
m ne soient pas informés de ce qui se
passe à porto ou inversement
donc il en va de même avec la région ile
de france
on n'imagine pas que les versaillais ont
les rambos du temps ne sache pas ce qui
se passe plus au nord du côté de cergy
ou plus à l'est des yvelines et d'1
longtemps au delà de paris à montreuil
ou en seine-et-marne
donc il est capital essentiel que
l'information circule le but quand même
c'est d'avoir des initiatives qui sont
positives 1 c'est bien ça l'idée
vraiment ce média c'est qu'avec les
informations qui sont partagés on puisse
agir soit on agit dans le sens de choisy
sa sortie culturelle on pouvait lire sa
sortie nature
en tout cas on a des idées pour occuper
son temps dans ce dans ce grand paris ou
sinon on a une information qui permet de
rejoindre une initiative qu'elle soit
environnementale qu'elle soit de l'ordre
de l'économie sociale et solidaire en
tout cas c'est consommer autrement par
exemple pour être plus concret on a fait
des sélections pour consommer local en
lisant ces sélections on peut décider de
consommer autrement avec les adresses
qui permettent de le faire très
prochainement on organise un événement
qui s'appelle ménages pont canal c'est à
paris et au long du le long des canaux
enfin à paris et en seine-saint-denis le
long des canaux parisiens et et de
seine-saint-denis on va pouvoir ramasser
collecter les déchets et en même temps
rencontrer des associations
environnementales qui agissent au
quotidien pour prendre soin de notre
notre environnement
donc on part en parler du site internet
on a aussi parlé rapidement des guides
il y en a deux qui sont parus récemment
en mars et qui concerne le territoire
des yvelines en a un sur versailles un
autre sur le vexin qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'apporte votre média en plus sur
ces guides
parce qu'on a des guides qui sont qu'ils
ont connue sur le territoire qu'est ce
qu'il ya de plus juste laisser parler
même pas ma concurrente de la sncf
bah si elle ne court pas trop ma voix ce
qui fait ce qui fait la différence c'est
qu'en fait des guides sur ile-de-france
y en a pas tant que ça il ya beaucoup
énormément le guide sur paris il y en a
des centaines
si vous comptez si vous commencez à
compter sur l'île de france il a très
peu et encore moins sur des portions de
territoires comme ce qu'on a voulu faire
avec ce guide de versailles et ce guide
du vexin le premier guide sur versailles
est sorti l'an dernier d'ailleurs il est
un premier guide sur versailles qui a
été qui a été écrit par départ de
versailles est un collectif de
versailles s qui s'agrippaient pour
écrire ce guide nous là ce n'est pas que
versailles c'est vers ça y est c'est sa
région on va dire ça comme ça et on va
jusqu'en vallée de chevreuse on monte un
peu plus un peu plus haut dans le du
côté de saint germain en laye et donc
c'est vide permettent de profiter au
maximum de tirer profit de découvrir les
richesses de ces deux territoires
franciliens c'est de pouvoir sur un
petit périmètre de mai avoir le maximum
de choses et y en a énormément
et justement vous avez sorti un audit
qui s'appelle autour de paris 20 balade
à portée de pass navigo
là c'est un design qui est un petit peu
différent on peut choisir sa destination
en fonction d'un thème qu'est ce qu'on
trouve à chaque destination en fait
alors laissé que vous avez des balades
soit à faire à pied soit avec nous et
donc vous arrivez vous avez un point de
chute qui peut être qui peut être saint
denis qui peut être sont elles n'ont
alors là je sors vraiment des yvelines
sinon versailles et à partir de là mon
rayonne soit à pied soit à vélo et on a
accès à des lieux du patrimoine
on a accès à des activités de loisirs à
des restaurants etc
l'idée c'est vraiment de concentrer sur
une destination un maximum d'offres pour
passer une journée noire deux jours
c'est ça l'idée
on peut faire du tourisme tout en
restant en ile-de-france avec un outil
qui est absolument magique s'appelle le
pass navigo et pour 75 euros où elle est
absolument partout c'est finalement on
peut on peut faire du tourisme sans
nécessairement quitter les frontières de
l'île de france et c'est ce qu'on
raconte sur ces guildes dans célibat et
sur la nahb pour chaque destination
c'est qu'on a vraiment un programme qui
est complet jusqu'au restaurant où on
peut manger et c'est vrai que c'est
assez complet dans ce guide justement
autour de paris donc il est quand même
question des yvelines il ya le musée de
la batellerie ou des lieux plus connu
comme le potager du roi ou la salle du
jeu de paume à versailles
vous qui connaissez bien ce territoire
puisque vous habitez dans les yvelines
depuis quelques temps ou est ce que vous
aimez vous balader ici dans les yvelines
alors dans les yvelines j'ai un faible
tout particulier et pas seulement parce
que j habite pour la haute vallée de
chevreuse qui pour moi est avant même
que j habite était un des plus beaux
coins de france et le reste est là on a
accès à une nature qui est
déjà préservée qui est magnifique avec
la forêt de rambouillet qui est quand
même plus grande que paris ça on l'a pas
forcément en tête une forêt plus grande
que paris n'est avec des pistes
cyclables en plus qui sont souvent des
vertes pour les fréquenter régulièrement
je pleins témoigné
et c'est ici qu'a me permettre de
sillonner absolument toute la forêt et
puis d'avoir accès à une nature qui est
belle celle que celle dont on a vraiment
besoin
depuis justement les confinements
successifs on voit ça ce besoin de
nature est exprimé par les par les
citadins et est ce qu'on a vu d'ailleurs
ce qui s'est matérialisé l'an dernier
par des débouchant parfois dans
certaines foires et française en
particulier la forêt de fontainebleau et
donc bas plutôt que d'attendre d'être
confiné pour profiter de cette nature
l'idée c'est que c'était de dire
profitez-en tout le temps et pour ça il
faut être informé et bien informée c'est
ce que vous faites
évidemment comme comme chaînes locales
et c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire en
tant que média local
et justement vous avez parlé des
confinement quel impact il a eu le coup
vite sur votre média est ce que
justement les gens aller plus souvent
sur votre média à la recherche de
petites balades
est-ce que c'était difficile pour vous
aussi trouvé des choses qui étaient
ouverts simplement a tout changé
ça a tout changé dans la conception
moi je considère que le grand paris est
née en mai 2020 pourquoi je dis ça parce
que d'un seul coup
nous on a vu dans le trafic de daniel
jean parisse
on était à 70 mille lecteurs en avril
2001 et puis dans les mois qui précèdent
et on est passé à 300 mille lecteurs
on met en bonis va pourquoi parce que
d'un seul coup toute l'information on
produisait depuis sept ans à trouver un
public
une demande qui s'est manifestée bas par
des requêtes sur google
qu'est-ce que je peux faire avec ce
rayon de 100 km qui m'empêche de quitter
l'île de france
ah tiens il ya des trucs à faire en ile
de france je le découvre et finalement
ça a été une bonne opportunité
même si elle n'était pas choisi de
s'emparer de s'approprier la région et
cette contrainte donc permis de changer
l'âme en fait de changer la carte
mentale qu'on a de forêt de ce
territoire qui étaient concentrées sur
sur paris à tous les yeux tournés vers
paris là on a pu on a même eu ressentiez
besoin de détourner le regard et de
s'intéresser à ce qu'il y avait autour
il ya une infographie qu'on a produite
il ya très longtemps qu'on peut trouver
sur le site d'un agent paris qui est
intéressante elle montre que si on
compare les métropoles leur superficie
donc si on compare baril à new york par
exemple
paris fait 100 kilomètres carrés et
miller fait 1200 km câble est bien dans
new york on à versailles mais on a la
forêt de versailles
on a là feraient trop se repose on a
même un bon du parc naturel oise pays de
france qui rentre dans le bronx et la
forêt de montmorency qui est à la place
du parc de central park
finalement on a la chance d'être dans
une région qui est relativement petite
qui est très bien desservi avec 381
gares et on plan profiter grâce au pass
navigo et accéder à la culture la nature
et du patrimoine
merci beaucoup renaud charles pour votre
présence aujourd'hui
merci à vous j'espère que voilà vous
m'avez entendu et maintenant voilà il
suffit le hino suffit plus les hangars
et puis de prendre une destination
francilienne
c'est ça on a tout à apporter de pass
navigo
merci beaucoup et merci aux voilà
beaucoup avouent pardon d'avoir suivi
cette émission on te retrouve bientôt
dans un nouveau vite
[Musique]